Let's
head over to Ukraine
and growing speculation about the timing
of a critical counter
offensive against Russian forces there.
CNN's Nick Paton Walsh reports
from the Southern Front.
Change is in the air,
but here in Valletta, Russia is the same
and its intensity
and clumsiness of bombing.
It's not clear
if this tiny town is a launchpad
for Ukraine's counteroffensive,
but Moscow pounded.
Just to be sure,
a similar story here,
too, on the riverbank
near has on the reportedly
Ukrainian forces may be crossing
into occupied areas.
Their officials claiming
quote, impressive results on Tuesday.
A Russian airstrike hit
even though it's unclear
what they struck.
Ukraine's otherwise kept quiet
about its big assault.
Despite some opaque
social media videos suggesting movement,
Russian troops are,
according to one Ukrainian official
from the occupied town of multiple
definitely on the move.
Now we see that they relocated
they make to two great big bases
for Russian troops.
All of this base is located on its side.
So Olga is obviously more than
100 kilometers from the frontlines.
He joked about how common accidents
are there for Russians.
One overturning this launcher,
especially on the railway,
vital for military supplies.
Maybe three weeks.
There is no electricity on the railway.
And so they use all diesel trains.
And a few days ago,
something happened with diesel trains and
it was a great fire.
And now there is no diesel.
When you say something happened,
you mean there was an explosion
and you know something about that
Something happened
early on.
We spoke to one local man
who fled the city
four days ago to mention you
proper Russian troops aren't there yet.
It's just the newly mobilized
who would not fight
if they weren't threatened
by being shot for discipline
to do to do what
everyone, locals,
suspects, everyone else.
If something,
even people who would drink vodka with
you can't talk to you now.
Really? Well.
Still, Moscow keeps up with what it calls
evacuations.
There's another episode
of Ukrainian children
being sent to what Russia calls safety
here.
43 from an area
right in the path of the counter
offensive packed off
to Moscow's
ally Belarus for a two week break.
Others in the past
were offered a similar trip,
but held for months.
Ukraine has said 20,000
have been deported already
and it's led to a war crimes
indictment against Russian
President Vladimir Putin.
It's unclear what comes next for them
and the town in the crosshairs
they leave behind.
Wolf, you might be able to hear the air
raid sirens behind me here.
Very common in that Perugia.
Real tension
and anxiety growing here
and the sense possibly
that things in Ukraine's long awaited
counter offensive may be beginning.
Are we seeing the prelude to that
beginning in the activity
on the eastern bank of her
soul on the river?
We don't know.
But clearly a sense
that things are moving Wolf.
Nick Paton Walsh, stay safe over there.
Thank you very, very much.